il a beaucoup été question d'europe
entre les deux ministres et plus
particulièrement des relations dégradées
entre la russie et l'union européenne
pour sergueï lavrov cette rupture n'est
pas récente et remonte à 2014 lorsque
l'union européenne a décidé je cite
d'accuser moscou de tout ce qui se
passait en ukraine ce qui a lancé le
cycle de sanctions qui perdure encore
aujourd'hui
résultat tout ce qui existait en termes
de relation concrète entre la russie et
ses partenaires européens s'est retrouvé
détruits l'union européenne a résolument
détruit tous les mécanismes sans
exception qui existait sur la base des
accords de partenariat et de coopération
en commençant par les sommets et les
rencontres annuelles qui se faisait
entre les commissaires européens et le
gouvernement russes y compris sur les
projets qui coud qui comprenait
différents espaces de coopération les
rencontres sectorielles et l'essentiel
des contacts que nous avions ici et
notamment les séances de partenariat et
de coopération qui avait lieu chaque
année avec la participation des
ministres des affaires étrangères de la
russie et aux prises le représentant
pour les affaires étrangères de l'union
européenne et on a vu tous les formats
de discussions qui ont été détruits il a
également été question de la sphère
navalni et plus spécifiquement de
l'expulsion des trois diplomates
européens
d'après le ministre russe des affaires
étrangères ils ont contrevenu à leurs
prérogatives
ces diplomates bénéficier de l'immunité
à l'acception des cas quand il pratiquer
l'ingérence dans les affaires
intérieures
donc on a eu des exemples très claire de
type d'ingérence qui sont tout à fait
incompatible avec eux
une mission diplomatique s'est plaint
notamment quand il parle participent à
des manifestations politiques dans le
pays malgré les différends l état actuel
des relations entre moscou et l'union
européenne
sergey lavrov ne ferme pas la porte pour
autant à plusieurs reprises lors de
cette conférence de presse à la fin de
ces heureusement de ces démonstrations
il a souligné que la russie était
disposée à tout moment à rétablir de
bonnes relations avec ses partenaires
européens encore faut-il que cette
volonté existe